falls schnell und so für noch zwei ja
noch 1 4 gar keine mehr
fünfter noch eine menge ok 5 noch zwei
jetzt jetzt noch einer 57 es noch eine
menge und sechs auch noch ein bisschen
ok 6 und jetzt nochmal
topf 6 ist jetzt noch einer und sieben
sind noch jetzt noch vier nehme jetzt
auch einer diskussion im saint quest
findet vermischt ich habe mein cards so
lemmer gedrückt gewesen womit mainka ca
hier geht's runter weil ich ja endlich
geht zurück
ich möchte einfach mal wieder ganz viele
meint sind herauf
wo bleibst du mein karte ist stehen
geblieben
nein falsche richtung scheiße scheiße
alter was ich habe extra allem einen
zweck geschwister ich dachte ich nur
eins der teuersten laufen
darauf möchte ich kann jetzt geben dann
kommt hinterher in marl hüls mich ein
aber das ist schon vorbei ich hab's
geschafft was war ist jetzt schon die
and end and dingens nedas auch eine
technische wieder drei folgen china 3 4
stunde
ach ja ich hab's geschafft europa wo ich
bin
wieso ist sie endlich offen ich bin bei
minecraft ist die falsche richtung
gefahren aber auch deswegen war um das
loch man ist das cool ja toll aber die
ente ist nicht offen
hier ist ganz viel rats telepathie ich
mal zu mir die ente ist nicht offen
kpt okay ich mache die kunst immer kurz
zu offen um zu sehen was dahinter ist
hell warte ich lieber noch mal ganz kurz
so war das hier weil das kug martin wenn
du richtig gefahren das beste heraus
gekommen
ja ich kann es wahrscheinlich hat man
seinen hut nehmen muss und dann hier
drauf setzen müssen dann wenn man
hierher weitergefahren
genau erwartet da muss man noch kurz
main cup holen
ich komme da nicht ich hab mein card
erwartet natürlich zu nehmen
doch da oder was auf dem schwarze war
ich gerade glaube ich ahne ich war doch
tiefer fällt schnell und so ich sehe das
wirklich einfach daran dass ich kein
mein kater hat okay dachte eine
fehlerlose partie
da kommt man gar nicht hoch die parteien
fehler du bist bei mir unsichtbar bei
mir bist auch und sichtbar machen wir
das gleich wenn wir fertig sind
janka hat alles möglich hier ist gar
nichts außer aussicht
hier ist wieder da wenn wir nicht doch
da bist wir müssen jetzt wieder runter
hast du lämmer oder so nein israel
schalter oben gedrückt
ja ich glaube schon
bleib du mal kurz danke hier sagen ob
ich den gedrückt habe ich kann auch
wieder zurücklaufen
ok es regnet ok dämpfer charaktere sind
hier bäume pressure blades ich verstehe
es nicht anders da wieder hoch
hier war nix geht immer wieder zurück
hatte ich mal kurz doppel down voll da
ist nix sich auf den plattformen
das ende ist jetzt glaube ich auf dem
balkon ihres redstone signal das geht
bis nach dahinten das heißt wir müssen
jetzt ein meinhard nehmer ok und damit
wieder zurück fahren bestimmt auf den
fersen
ich trete ich bin so komisch gedriftet
gerade ich sehe ich mich auch was für
ein zufall aber ich esse ich sowieso
cool anja da kann ich auch mit opti find
a und 9 prozent die w end des offen auch
wenn er keine blöcke sind egal wer für
den abgebauten zu gucken ob dahinter
vielleicht irgendwann ist irgendwie hhc
york wo bis zu hemd darunter gesprungen
scheiße doch ich habe mein gott ich habe
noch 18 uhr scheiße
dann nehme ich das jetzt einfach immer
mit ich bin stehengeblieben schlussmann
mike card jedoch nicht da sind auch
nicht gebrauchte dinge berichten paar
fehler die rechtschreibfehler
weggelassen
rechtschreibfehler hat zudem hier
redstone fehler jetzt fährst du wieder
bei mir eine jetzt ist wieder da bei mir
bin ich da ja jetzt bist du auf ihr da
ich verstehe dass ich das ja ich habe
manchmal einfach so phasen verschwindet
bei wem es keine ahnung an die gräfin
taktieren ist irgendwo runtergefallen
ich auch
ja das freut mich was das jetzt ja das
war's dts red
es kann nämlich sein als ob die
entlassung so billig ist dabei gar
nichts das war das ende
das heißt ende im gelände die endlich
gelang nur kurz bleiben creatives fliege
ich hierher kann sich zum importieren
unten
erst hier ach das habe ich gar nicht
gesehen
made by and grey grantig robbie maddison
akku das ist ja echt vorbei ja gut meine
lieben freunde
das war's mit der challenge map r
nein die man sich nicht ganz gut
bisschen schwer manchmal muss ich sagen
nein findet menschen mal war das echt
wenig philipp diplomat ich glaube du
kennst anderen maps noch nicht so bei
anderen mit teilweise 5 6 folgen dann in
so einem scheiß sprung ohne zu chatten
aha na ja interessant machen wir nun
dass martin und luca ranking was wir das
mal kein ranking von zehn diamanten
wieviel diamanten wird zudem abgeben
es war die frage ist wo bist du auf dem
dach von dem goldenen guckt also was
sagst du ich sage dass ich sage also ich
muss schon sagen an sicher ist die map
ja ganz schön gestaltet und alles ganz
nett gemacht mit dem hier und so aber
mit dem hier und so halt wenig ganzen
fehlern und so was machst du da das ist
echt kacke dass diese items unserer
texte packs noch nicht gerettet
haha schmeckt euch alles in der luft
wenn der aufgeladene steht oben steht
rot etf ach du scheiße ja ich sag's dir
springt dann alles in der luft was sag
ich und er lässt den etat stern fallen
irgendwo hier ist er das nicht tut also
ist noch nicht tot
mit eiern hier bei mir ist eh schon tot
er wusste denn war der fläche oben so
rum da ja ich weiss weshalb des radios
ist online erschießt er bösen köpfe der
tod nein gar nicht seine gesundheit ich
habe mich beim besteht rot-rot nicht
wegfliegen
sonst kommt
hast du was aufgesammelt nein du bist du
hier oben ist das runter gefallen
er keine ahnung gut wie viele diamanten
wird zudem abgeben
ich gebe der map also mein herz sagt 7
aber mein kopf sagt 611 das passiert
sagt oder st nein ich sage acht oder
neun ich sogar neun weil es nicht geben
es hat alles geklappt also mischung 8
ich sage 18 19 10
martin und luca bist du ich bin wieder
auf dem goldenen dachl wurde wo es am
anfang war da so party-marathon super so
und da alle darauf gewartet haben
also ja endlich was ist doch jetzt oder
was das jetzt von der veb das war es
eigentlich schon feuerwerk darauf haben
alle gewartet
es muss fliegen
ich freue auch alles explodiert
supergeil wir machen einfach mal die
komplette welt kaputt die er alles
aufgebaut hat im internet runterladen
was auch tnt echt alles in luft geflogen
er habe ich night vision oder die ja so
walter rasch ok cool
das war es meine lieben freunde wie
immer wenn ihr das bedeutet dann
schreibt das einfach in die kommentare
oder bewertet das video mit einem daumen
hoch wenn es euch gefallen hat oder mit
einem tom rother wenn es mich nicht so
gefallen hat würde ich sagen
sehen wir uns als die next time to use
meiner seite aus von martin seite von
miroslav lajcak sprechers nicht über 1 1
doch ehrlich zu dir teleportieren sie
zum schluss so hallo martin
ich habe schon meine aufnahme aufgemacht
aktuellen kaders